I've been saying this too no I've been
saying this too because every time I
come to the West it seems that you know
they're just trying to put more
accountability on men and take more
accountability from women I don't know
if you guys agree with me or disagree
definitely but I see that like because
you know there's so many like how many
gigantic men positive social movements
have you seen were name one hashtag
campaign for men men go their own way
hashtag I'm surprised you know that so
that's not a mainstream though that was
men who made it their own but then all
these other ones that have been
engineered by these corporations and
these social media where's the one for
men where's the one like hashtag
fraternity rights for men change divorce
lights